hello this is Justin and today I'm going
to go over two of Magnus Carlson's games
from the Champions chess T now if you
don't know Magnus Carlson is the best
chess player ever debated considered the
goat in chess he's been the highest
rated chess player for over 10 years
he's won multiple World Championships
he's just on another level and he's so
good at chess
that openings just don't matter to him
he'll play whatever opening he wants
just to get a position because he knows
that he can outplay any opponent from
any position so this game right here is
against Fab ANUK caruana and Fabby is
currently the number two player in the
world so like this is number one versus
number two this is as good as it gets
and after
E4 Magnus played Knight to
C6 now it's really hard to explain how
crazy this is but I'll try my best
Knight to C6 is never played it's
considered a garbage opening like it's
really bad because white just gets the
center like white just gets the these
two pawns here for pretty much
nothing and he plays this against the
world number two that's just
crazy that he can he can play these
garbage openings and get away with it
cuz he's so good at chess so it's
like it's like playing good openings is
like trying to be successful and going
to college like it helps it's good but
you don't need to do it to be successful
so Magnus is like definitely not going
to college he's not even like going to
primary school he's
just avoiding all of the fundamental
openings all the principles just to get
a position because he knows no matter
what position he's going to be able to
outplay his opponents it's crazy so just
sit back relax and just let this game
wash over you see how he
absolutely dominates his opponent from a
position that's just crazy like he has
no control of the center right now and
we see later he absolutely dominates
it so to get back to the chest he plays
D5 here so he needs to fight back for
the center and this is how he does it um
the his kind of statement here is if you
take I'm going to take with the queen
and this is similar to a Scandinavian
which is E4 D5 except it's a little
different because this Pawn's already on
D4 so white has or sorry black has a lot
of pressure on that pawn KN F3 you can
play Bishop G4 you can Castle next and
this Rook is going to be attacking
D4 black he gets a pretty decent
initiative so instead of this white
plays
E5 and now black plays Bishop to F5 so
this is a a good move because we want to
get this bishop out of the the pawn
chain because we want to play E6 next so
we can get this bishop in so um this
position is kind of similar to a caroan
so a kakan would be like
this and then you get this bishop out
right so it's it's kind of still in the
realm of reasonable chess openings but
it's still absolutely crazy that that he
can play this and and just get get away
with it so after Bishop F5 um Knight to
F3 is
played and then E6 and Fabby plays
Bishop D3 which is a slate and accuracy
and already after six moves Magnus has
gotten a really pretty decent position
here he's playing against the world
number two considered by the way faon
and Caron is considered one of the best
theoreticians in the world like he knows
everything about every opening and it's
been six moves and Magnus is kind of
equalized he's gotten a decent position
of the opening it's crazy um because he
just didn't know what to do and Magnus
was able to outplay him from unfamiliar
territory so after all this Magnus plays
Queen
D7 and then just like I said before it
looks like white has crazy good control
of the center so black has to do
something about this so he breaks in the
center he tries to create this tension
here where he's going to be able to
fight back and gain some space back for
himself so White Castles takes takes and
he plays A5 here A5 is kind of an
interesting move definitely like a
Grandmaster move not a lot of uh low
rated players are going to play that the
reason is um if you were to like Castle
long here B4 would be very annoying CU
B5 is coming white is just going to roll
his pawns down the board and try to
crush you so plays A5 first and then
develops his Bishop very normal stuff A4
to stop the knight from coming to B3
so Carlson is very good about playing
prophylactically so that means he's
playing um to stop his opponent's ideas
so this A4 move is a great example
Knight to B3 would have been a move that
white wants to play to reroute this
Knight to a better square and he just
stops it so white kind of lashes out
with B4 takes so he still gets the
Knight on B3 but the difference is now
this Rook has this open line and white
doesn't have that open Line because his
Rook is stuck behind this
Pawn so we Retreat the bishop Bishop to
E3 R trade and lock plays B6 to keep
this knight from coming to
C5 Knight G5 Knight E7 so with this move
caruana is saying okay I'm going to go
after this pawn and you're not going to
be able to play G6 because anytime you
make a move that weakens the squares so
Queen G6 is
devastating and a very nasty check cuz
Knight F7 is coming um next or if the
King goes here Rook F3 it's just really
really bad um so this H Pawn's pretty
important um and Carlson just ignores it
he just plays Knight to E7 he says all
right you can have my pawn and this is
exactly what happens um because here he
plays Knight to F5 breaking the
connection here soobi plays Rook to H3
to maintain that connection now and
here Carlson
castles
wait what is this instead of castling
here he plays King to Da it looks like a
mouse
lip but it's not it's very intentional
he's just slowly marching his King over
to B7 very
leisurely not a care in the world just
I'm going to you know take some time
three moves precisely just to to bring
my king here and the reason he does this
is because if he were to Castle what
would happen is uh something like Queen
A6 and Knight C5 is really annoying and
essentially The Rook gets caught on the
wrong side of the king the Rook wants to
be on this open a file and it can't be
here I think I think here actually um
yeah I think Knight C5 is really
devastating but that's another story um
so he plays King d8 just absolutely
ridiculous what he's doing um and
then he just wins this Pawn in the
center he he could have taken it before
but he just is patient just reroutes his
Knights he shuffles a little bit and you
see all of a sudden white has no Center
pawns and black has two how did that
happen like he just he's just he's a
wizard like that's
insane all the sudden the center is just
absolutely
decimated um so he continues with this
plan um and now he's got a past Aon and
just kind of reflect on the center and
the open the center now he's just
completely flipped the script and all of
a sudden he's dominating that
Center um so after Queen B5 he's just
going to push this a pawn to Victory
um this Knight on C4 is really strong
too cuz it's on an outpost there's no
pawns that can attack it um and after A3
Knight to F7 there's this weird move
Queen B2 but he just plays the human
move Rook E8 and this a pawn is just too
strong um if you take here you can
actually take here giving up this Rook
for
free but the problem is this Pawn is one
square away from from queening and
there's nothing he can do to stop it so
for example King to D7 and black is just
going to Queen next and be completely
winning
so Bobby kind of extends the game a
little bit but that A2 Pawn is too close
to promotion
um for uh for Magnus so it's just going
to win the game Queen to B1 is the
finishing touch because after Rook takes
Queen he's just going to take back and
um he's up material he's also going to
mate um over here really shortly so just
a very devastating position and he's
dominating on all flanks every side of
the board he's got this open f file um
he had this a pawn that he pushed and
now he's got a lot of space over here to
to work some magic this Knight on C4 is
amazing and the center it's just it's
absolutely incredible how he went from
absolutely nothing in the center in the
opening absolutely nothing to all of a
sudden um dominating that Center so this
game really goes to show that openings
although they're important they don't
matter all that much it's more important
to focus on your chess make sure you're
a good chess player put in the work and
maybe you can play like Magnus someday
so I'm going to show another game um
that Magnus played um because this game
is just too good not to show um in the
same tournament he was white in this
game against Maxim vasia lrav also known
as
mvl
and man this game is just absolutely
crazy so opening starts out quite normal
um this isn't playing one Knight F3
isn't the most popular opening but it is
kind of um well known at the Grand
Master Level um and he just develops his
pieces he castles and what he's doing
now is double fian ketoing so he played
B3 so his Bishop will go to B2 and the
reason fian ketoing is good is because
we're putting our Bishops on the longest
diagonals on the board so we're kind of
maximizing their potential by allowing
them to be on these long diagonals so
after D4 um this isn't like a great open
for what like it's it's okay but Black's
pretty much equalized here because he
has more space and has capsule and
doesn't really have any
weaknesses um but Magnus finds a way so
he plays E3 to kind of fight back at the
center um and if black was to take here
um we would take back take towards the
center now we have two Center pawns they
have one and then if black were to play
D3 this Pawn is just going to end up
being a weakness here
um sooner or later it's just going to be
able to get wrapped up move like Knight
E5 already starts to put pressure on it
and just it's not going to last there
because it's too far away from its home
Camp so anyway Knight to C6 and you get
some trades in the center Magnus
develops um and here after playing
Knight C3 mvl plays Rook E8 he wants to
play E5 and develop this bishop and
Carlson just says no you can't play E5
I'm going to put my knight there and
this is a really annoying move because
how is he going to develop this bishop
you can't play Bishop to D7 because
whoops that B7 Pawn is hanging and what
else are you going to do like it's very
difficult for him to develop the rest of
his pieces so he plays Bishop to D6 he
wants to get rid of this Knight and play
E5 and again agna says no I'm going to
play F4 I'm going to cement this Knight
on E E5 and if you take it well that's
going to be very bad news I'm going to
take the F Pawn opening up this line for
my Rook I Queen's going to be able to
fly into H5 all of my pieces are going
to be able to work together in a very
very nice attack um so this is just no
good so after inducing this F4 move mvl
goes back to this diagonal to ISA King
and Carlson just Sid steps Queen E7
pretty normal stuff and here charlson
plays
G4 so he's pretty much developed most of
his pieces maybe he could get this rook
in the game but he realizes that this
Knight on E5 is really strong my pieces
are set up for an attack and black isn't
developed very well so these are all the
signs to say okay my opponent's not
ready I'm going to go attack plays G4 G5
just absolutely launching those pawns
towards his opponent's king and then
after this he needs more attackers right
you can't checkmate with just a knight
so he brings his other Knight in and
then to f8 Black's trying to defend
Magnus brings his Queen in so all of a
sudden he went from one attacker to
three and not only that but this bishop
and this rook and this other Bishop are
all in proximity all ready to to
potentially jump in for this attack so
Knight G6 and instead of trading we
don't want to trade our attackers we
want to keep them on the board and we
want to increase the pressure so he
plays Knight to G4 a very very strong
move and after this Magnus is saying I'm
going to play Knight to
F6 what are you going to do about it
like Knight to F6 is so strong he's
going to sacrifice a knight so we see
Bishop A3 Knight
F6 ignoring his opponent's move and
after this move black is just dead lost
so what happened was takes Pawn takes
and here um anytime this Pawn is on F6
very close to our opponent's king it's
very dangerous um for that King because
Queen coming to H6 followed by Queen
coming to G7 that's going to be very
deadly so here M plays Queen to B4 and
now Queen H6 would actually be uh a
mistake because it looks like all right
we're going to come in here with the
queen
but black has a sneaky move Knight to F5
attacking the queen and covering G7 and
all of a sudden black is doing just fine
and he's going to actually be able to
win a piece so Magnus still had to be a
little careful here instead he found the
correct move again bringing another
attacker closer to that King and Knight
to G5 threatening Queen 6 H7 is going to
be very deadly and that's exactly what
happened we're threatening Queen takes
F7 now
Rook D7 and all of Black's pieces are
tied down so Carlson just plays the calm
Bishop takes D4 because this Rook is
overworked can't defend F7 and D4 so mvl
resigned in this position a 23 move win
against a super Grandmaster that's just
unheard of and Carlson did it with ease
it seemed so easy to him so it's just
absolutely insane how good you can get
at chess and if you put in the work
maybe you can be like Magnus too so
thanks for
watching um hopefully you learned a
thing or two and I'll see you in the
next video